you the most Russian man in
my life bro
try to pretend he ukrainians I would
have some sympathy I know you're not
Ukrainian this guy got a
van with 12 inches handcuffed in a in
the parking lot right now hey hey you
want to stop human trafficking and lock
this up right now you make
a big start you'll give Liam niece and
his daughter back y'all
and if you are Ukrainian anyways for
staying here when they at War
[Laughter]
you're all ukrainians son y'all some
cowards yo
what the hell is this it's for
ukrainians you front row oh no you could
be front line for the comedy show but
not Freedom huh
fell out ass dudes paid for premium
seating ain't sending no money back home
I'm disgusting
thank you for coming though please keep
laughing
[Applause]